from awesome cena action lost in time
captain america shields a deleted batman
parody and up to nine alternate endings
there's a lot that marvel deleted from
the final version of the tunnels yupikai
movie lovers i'm jan and in this video
i'm revealing all the cutscenes and
characters alternate post-credits scenes
and deviant designs that ended up
getting the chop spoilers ahead of
course so take care
there was a great looking scene with
cena in the first trailer that didn't
make it into the movie which seems to be
part of what makari and kingo's actors
have described as a visually spectacular
deleted scene set during the flashback
to the gupta empire the scene involved a
lot of silk and would have established
the two types of eternals the thinkers
that's cersei ajak fastos sprite and
droog and the fighters that's icarus
gilgamesh thiena makari and kingo it was
intended to show how the family were
both dysfunctional and fun at the same
time but was cut for pacing which given
the length of the movie makes sense
what's especially intriguing about this
deleted scene is that this guy here is
carrying a shield very similar to steve
rogers famous captain america shield
that's strange because chronologically
in the main mcu timeline it was howard
stark who first created cap shield in
the 20th century
whereas the gupta scenes and eternals
take place in 400 a.d many hundreds of
years earlier steve rogers did of course
decide to go time travelling at the end
of avengers end game for his rendezvous
with peggy carter and he also brought
back a new captain america shield for
sam wilson so did he also decide to go
back further in time and have something
to do with the shield we see in this
scene alternatively and more likely
fastos invented this shield and kept it
in storage on the eternal ship and
released the idea for it later on in
time to howard stark similar to how he
slowly introduces other technology over
the years to humankind in this film
a line widely used in the eternals
trailers and tv spots but which didn't
make it into the final movie is when
icarus says eternal's assemble to prove
a good lie it's a nod of course to the
comics and that awesome moment when capp
finally said the famous line in end game
as he called for earth's mightiest
heroes to wade into battle against
thanos avengers assemble another deleted
line from the trailers would have come
at the end of the movie when sprite is
sitting with icarus watching the volcano
erupt as the emergence begins this is
what the end of the world looks like at
least we have front row seats the
character i really enjoyed in the film
was kingo and the comedic moments that
both he and his human friend karun
brought to the story the documentary
they begin filming on kingo's jet is
hilarious and reminds me of the thor
mockumentaries and in fact there's an
avengers name drop in the trailers that
was cut from the final movie the
avengers thor spiderman another deleted
scene from kingo's jet has sprite
holding a microphone and performing what
looks like karaoke the others behind her
appear to be sleeping and given the
several cocktails on the bar it looks
like this is some kind of party scene on
the jet
an area where i thought the movie did
impress was its visual style especially
the deviants which had some particularly
striking looks the scene where their
leader crow uses his tentacles to
transform the other deviants in the cave
into monstrous winged and wolf-like
creatures was especially shocking
however there were some even more
horrifying deviant designs that didn't
make it into the film leaked concept art
shows froglike creatures and scorpion
style monsters that weren't in the final
movie the frog-like deviant might have
been based on the marvel character
brother toad who in the comics was a
ruler of the ancient deviant empire and
also commanded the deviant warlord crow
the name on the concept art for the
scorpion deviant indicates the creature
was based on a mythological mesopotamian
half-human half-scorpion creature i
think this would have been an especially
interesting deviant for the babylonian
attack given how these scorpion
creatures appear in the epic of
gilgamesh interestingly the real world
myths of the scorpion men say they were
created by the ocean goddess tiamat
whose name is reminiscent of tiamut the
celestial whose birth in the indian
ocean is stopped by cersei these other
deviant designs which appear to be by
concept artist tully summers seem to
have inspired the look of some of the
other versions of the deviants in the
movie such as the winged monster the
wolf-like beast and the long-legged
almost spider-like creatures some of the
humanoid designs also appear to be the
inspiration for crowe's more human-like
appearance that he acquires as the movie
goes on
as well as deleted antagonists there
were also two eternal characters cut
from the final film director chloe zau
revealed that there were 12 eternals in
the original script but that two of them
had to be let go ancho screenwriters kaz
and ryan firpo elaborated on deadlines
podcast saying that although marvel
initially asked for 12 characters after
the first draft they felt it was just
too many brand new characters to
introduce all at once to the mcu
audience one of those deleted characters
was vampiro a somewhat obscure eternal
who despite his name and fangs isn't a
vampire in fact he's more of a batman
knockoff in terms of his suit look and
use of high-tech gadgets given the
numerous dc references already in the
movie that's superman with the cape and
you're shooting laser beams out of your
eye a batman style character with
certainly a fit in however it's just as
well the number of eternals was cut down
because even with 10 the film did feel
somewhat overstuffed and thinking back
to guardians of the galaxy for example
their team began with just five new
characters
in true marvel style eternals has a
couple of post-credits scenes setting up
new story lines in the mcu however
screenwriter kasper pose revealed that
there were a total of nine post-credit
scenes originally considered for the
film in an interview with metro he
explained that each of the possible
versions of the ending told a different
story with different characters and
different ideas and he added that some
of them were really spicy given what we
know about marvel's upcoming movie slate
are the possibilities for the end credit
scenes could have been doctor strange 2
or thor love and thunder but what would
you have liked to have seen
while discussing his stunt work and
training drug actor barry keown revealed
that his mind controlling character had
at least one fight scene cut from the
film in an interview with comic book
movie he said that writer director chloe
had written a boxing scene and his
character was avoiding punches and the
tail and stuff like that which sounds
like he might have had a fight scene
with either icarus and also perhaps crow
or possibly another deviant given he
says that droog was avoiding a tale by
the way actor keown is actually a bit of
an amateur boxer in real life some other
scenes cut from the final film include
shots in the trailer of a longer opening
scene cersei passing her hand over crops
in babylon which has echoes of thanos
the farmer in endgame tending to his
crops and ajax saying hell yes during
her reunion with icarus at the house in
south dakota
and it wouldn't be a marvel movie
without some altered trailer scenes that
ended up quite different in the final
film in the past these have been done
either to avoid giving away spoilers or
just filmed exclusively for promotional
purposes so in the first eternals
trailer when thiena wields her sword at
this moment her eyes are normal whereas
in the movie this scene takes place
while she has the mad weary and so her
eyes are actually white when cersei says
it's beautiful to icarus in the first
trailer it appears to happen as the
eternals arriving on earth whereas in
the movie this moment happens just after
the eternals have been created and the
view outside the window is very
different with cersei and icarus looking
down on earth from space and when icarus
suggests he could lead the avengers now
that iron man and steve rodgers aren't
around the trailer follows up with
everyone bursting into laughter so now
that captain rogers and iron man are
both gone who do you think's gonna lead
the avengers i could lead
[Music]
in the them however that reaction
doesn't happen and instead kingo agrees
with icarus whereas gilgamesh simply
points out that ajax didn't even choose
him to lead the eternals another
alternate trailer scene is a cool
close-up of makari speed reading her way
through a book whereas in the final
movie the shot is only seen from much
further out and it doesn't quite have
the same effect so do you wish any of
these deleted scenes have been included
in the film and how do you rate eternals
compared to your favorite mcu movies
comment with your thoughts below and if
you enjoyed this video a thumbs up and a
share are hugely appreciated next you
can tap left to learn how black widow
solo movie almost ended with her
returning from the dead thanks for
watching and see you next time yippee
kai movie lovers